ko für spd und fdp bei der wahl in nrw
cdu und grüne feiern sich aber
eigentlich hat niemand grund zum jubeln
eigentlich haben alle verloren denn nur
gut jeder zweite bürger ist überhaupt
zur wahl gegangen ein historischer
tiefstwert ein dramatisches warnsignal
an die politiker die viele menschen
nicht mehr erreichen so wie in duisburg
marxloh
nordrhein westfalen hat gewählt und die
cdu jubelt mit fast 36 prozent wird die
union mit dem amtierenden
ministerpräsidenten hendrik wüst zum
sieger gekürt
kein grund zum feiern bietet hingegen
die wahlbeteiligung nur 55,5 prozent
setzen ihr kreuz rekordtief in
nordrhein-westfalen in zahlen von knapp
13 millionen wahlberechtigten sind rund
sechs millionen zu hause geblieben
besorgniserregend finden zumindest
einige politiker bei aller freude über
das grüne wahlergebnis die geringe
wahlbeteiligung muss allen
demokratischen parteien sorge machen
darauf gibt es nicht die eine einfache
antwort aber es muss uns allen ein
auftrag sein stärker an dem thema zu
arbeiten und hier im ruhrgebiet genauer
gesagt in duisburg marxloh juckte diese
sogenannte kleine bundestagswahl die
wenigsten gerade einmal 38 prozent
wahlbeteiligung im stadtteil die
niedrigste des landes und der grund
dafür kaum zu glauben viele haben uns
gesagt landtagswahl habe ich nichts von
gewusst wir haben mit einem türkischen
mitbürger gesprochen er sagte er sei
selber nicht wahlberechtigt er habe
davon aber tatsächlich auch nichts
gewusst seine frau sei deutsche die habe
aber tatsächlich auch nicht gewählt eine
von vielen in duisburg-marxloh aber so
richtig überrascht sind die bürger hier
nicht was soll ich da ran überraschend
wer soll hier wählen gehen die leute die
hier leben tatsächlich die noch übrig
geblieben sind das sind meistens
bulgaren rumänen die mit dem normalen
geschehen hier nichts mehr zu tun haben
wenn ich hätte das paket das ergebnis
die die wellen dürfen muss auch deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft haben und hier in
marcs vorfahren sind nicht so viele ich
finde es nur schade das ergebnis warum
das so ausgegangen ist schade findet
dass auch der cdu direktkandidat aus dem
duisburger norden deniz güner wir haben
hier die themen gesetzt hohe
arbeitslosigkeit desolate
bildungsinfrastruktur
organisierte kriminalität fehlende
visionen für die stadt bei der
entwicklung vielleicht haben wir die
messe ich nicht rüber transportieren
können aber auf der anderen seite geht
es ja auch letzten endes darum dass man
die wählerinnen und wähler mobilisiert
dann wählen zu gehen und das kreuz an
der richtigen stelle zu machen das ist
uns nicht gelungen wie das gelingen kann
ist jetzt die wichtigste aufgabe der
politik denn eine demokratie in der die
hälfte der wähler zu hause bleibt ist
besorgniserregend